the micro animals these are multi-celled
eukaryotes just like you and me animals
like Hydra which can theoretically live
forever tardigrades that can survive the
vacuum of space rotifers that have
thousands of cells with specialized
muscles intestines even brains kinda so
they are in many ways like us
but they also have some traits that
sound otherworldly tardigrades are
hatched with the exact same number of
cells in their body that they will
always have and these tiny baby water
bears then only grow as their cells grow
bigger and yet these animals are so
small that sometimes a single-celled
organism can swallow them whole
sorry little rotifer it's important to
note that one cell can be a thousand
times smaller than another cell so a
rotifer can have thousands of cells but
still be dwarfed by one protist